he hates the kid he finds like a kid
some relative I think is down by the
pond on this ranch it sequestering
and he's like hey you should go fish on
the other side because right now the Sun
is testing your shadow and the kids know
I can't get to the other side how come
he's oh I don't know how to swim what
you don't know how to swim and he picks
the kid up and supposed to hit the
middle of the life or the pond right
thought was and that was crazy that was
the way they did teach you even when I
was little I went to the YMCA my mom's
all you need swimming lessons you got a
wife what girl just has all lined up on
the deep end of the pool on the thing
and if she's up she goes and gets us and
she swims us out to the middle and like
let's go what they will never know it's
not probably not the best way to swim
but I don't think you can get out of the
fact that at some point you have to go
for it no matter how incremental your
teaching is at some point you have to go
for it do you understand you can't you
can't be holding back and you have to be
careful of all the good reasons that
you'll come up with for why you're not
jumping off the edge of the pool so to
speak right you just have to go for it
it's just not good it's never it never
comes out good when you walk up that you
remember the high dive when you're a kid
it never works out well for you when you
go you walk up you walk the ladder you
go to the edges and you're gonna get
ready that never works they just making
it worse right and that's where you see
all those belly flops and all that
crap and maybe sometimes you walk down
because you can't get over that it's
just like the sick and you touch the
steel of the ladder you just have to go
go go go go keep going that that kind of
taking that leap off that thousand foot
pole using gogans analogies that right
what what how do you want to understand
that you you have to realize that there
is a tendency in us to wait to delay to
try to have everything perfect
before we go but I you'll you'll realize
that the why are you doing that because
underneath that is a fear underneath
that is a fear and what you're trying to
do is wait for the fear to subside but
it doesn't go away by those means it
only goes away by jumping off the high
dive right and then you do ever I
remember it so maybe I was a little more
aware than some people but I was
flabbergasted by the people who would
come off that dive and go oh yeah it was
so much fun like we were little right
and we went to like the college pool and
you know in the summer they'd open it up
and so you know the colleges were you do
high dive stuff so we you'd go on diving
no watch my friends and you know they
would just pull one they'd come out oh
yeah it was great and then there's no
way that's great it's just not great
what would where did they all have in
common nobody stopped at the top
everyone just did what I did just touch
the pole now you're up don't touch that
don't touch it you know what I mean by
the pole the sides of the ladder that
you used to climb up don't touch it if
you're gonna stop do not scrape your
damn chin on the way up because your
foot slips but keep the hell walking get
up don't even look around
don't try and find anyone just start
walking out and voila and you go and
then it's enjoyable they have a section
in the arranger qualifications where
they test for fear of heights right and
you can see it
anybody who stops walking no you're
toast
you're not gonna keep going right you
just have to go
have you ever maybe you haven't done
high dives or arranged or qualifications
but you probably have done at some point
a balance beam the balance beam could be
like you know even four feet or I'm
sorry even like four inches off the
ground
if you overanalyze it you won't keep
your balance
it could be wide enough even that
clearly you can put a foot on there
right and walk its way wider than your
balance requires but if you overanalyze
it you'll find it's not wide enough I
need a sidewalk right but you'll but you
can really if you just keep going
you realize holy cow I can totally walk
that thing that is plenty wide and the
same thing when you see people that are
kind of you know hesitant hesitating
going over the balance beam versus that
person that's trying to win the obstacle
course and they just run across it why
cause it was wide enough my foot doesn't
need that much space when I my normal
running gait is plenty there's plenty of
room on there but when I want it perfect
because there's a fear that I might come
off of it then presto magico it is now
not wide enough so here you are at some
point you need to gain control of this
technique and there is a lot of fear
subsiding when you feel you have control
but the downside of that is that you now
start to do the move to sequentially or
or to staccato-like and it doesn't work
you don't have control now so in your
effort
hurry up and get control with one thing
before you gain control with the other
things you don't get control because the
control came as a harmony of all the
elements working together simultaneously
so your worst nightmare comes true the
arms slipped out of course it's going to
slip out you don't have everything
working you're waiting but they're
moving because gravity and inertia is
working on them so at some point you
have to go like a big John Wayne uncle
come and throw you in the pool you gotta
throw yourself in the pool get off the
edge go or like little David I terrified
eyes you'll never know it because I can
do it but in my head I don't like I like
that was one time in Japan I locked
myself out of my room and I was on the
fourth floor and I was terrified I felt
bad that I kept bothering my landlady
for like a million things right I was
just that stupid foreign guy that was
this couldn't figure out you know how do
you hook up the phone how do you get
Wi-Fi where's the bank how does it ATM
world I'm like asking her for everything
right and she just helped me with how to
how to use the bathroom I couldn't
figure out how to get in the back and
riding she's totally like is there
anything else is there anything else no
no there's nothing else and this came by
like two days after I was really sick
and dying basically my room from a fever
but had no idea how to get to a hospital
or a doctor or anything and all my
Japanese friends were trying to call me
and I didn't wasn't figure I didn't know
how to work the phone so it wasn't
ringing and I
like going to school I was dying on this
Oh carpet in my room right oh I couldn't
read what was you know aspirin and not
so it's just dying there and she's all
knocking on the door you know like
forever forever and I'm like and she
didn't know like could she could you is
this the worst day so she finally comes
in super embarrassed that she had to
come in my room you know and she see she
got all the medicines for me it's just a
landlord trying to stop my just nothing
to do with me friend or relationship so
they two days later after she helped me
with the bathroom okay great good and I
leave my key in the freaking room and I
was like I can't I can't go bother her
again she said such an angel and I'm
sitting there and I'm looking at this
building and I have always done rock
climbing that's crazy too if he I've
always done that and I'm looking at
building and I'm all I could I was
raining I don't know I could do it I
could do I know I could do it I know I
left that window open up there on the
balcony so I tell my neighbors right
well hey I'm gonna climb the building
they were from dead Laurel if I die I'm
down so I go up and I make it it there
right and I had night nurse for a good
year and a half of me slipping in the
rain and that like that's how afraid I
am of heights but you can never tell you
just you just let go go do it
okay and so no matter how incrementally
we make our training or we dissect our
techniques at a certain point you have
to go for it
okay do you guys understand you have to
and I really think that this is the
difference you know or one of the
differences one of the gateways that you
can use to transfer yourself from
beginner level to intermediate level you
you now are going for it it doesn't
matter if you don't make it
do you understand doesn't matter if your
belly flop or stings your feet or you
land when you're back where all the
water goes up in your nose you went for
it and the next one you're gonna go for
it too
you have to stop training so safely in
other words do you guys understand that
okay all right any questions or comments
on the technique a couple of things I
wish you would have known faster the the
all Akiho Wazza is cultivation training
whether it be a matter of your cultivate
in your mind their cultivating your your
body conditioning your body organization
your structure you cook you the that's
what they are they are not self defense
techniques you're not learning risk
wraps for example so as a result I need
to do them in such a way that they are
one actually cultivating my up actually
cultivating me okay and what you find by
a consequence of that is they are
transferable from fixated movement like
grips to ballistic movement like strikes
I can tell you if you do if you do or if
you see a fixated movement architectural
response that you look at go that will
never work on a strike you're looking at
someone who does not understand the art
fully okay so don't be that person make
sure that your movements actually
correspond to the universal pattern that
is part of the very crest that marks
this school and that those movements
because they are part of that universal
pattern they do cultivate your body and
they do
for from fixated movement to ballistic
movement okay so everything we do for a
grab you can't do for a strike for
example okay so with your little chair
back row arms you're not gonna you can't
do striking like that and you can't do
nice defense and you can't do you know
baton fighting it's you can't hold the
gun like that all that kind of stuff
okay so you make sure you understand
that about your own training we're not
just learning wrist grabs so I can't
just come up with a solution that only
works for a wrist strap